les super héros ils sont beaux ils sont
puissants et ça devrait être interdit de
les imiter
vous aurez reconnu captain america
attire pas mal wolverine
havas est monté plus plus bon les gars
on est gentil on va ranger son legging
car aujourd'hui la grosse artillerie de
sortie avec justice league
justice league c'est quoi c'est le
premier film du studio dc comics qui
réunissait tête de gondole batman wonder
woman aquaman cyborg des flashs
et sous ses airs de fashion week du
kitsch et là c'est flash qui défilent
dans une avant-gardiste combi en peau de
babybel le film et surtout la réponse de
dc comics à son adversaire marvel la
maison de hulk spiderman captain america
ou encore iron man vous suivez c'est
bien depuis les années 30 ces deux
maisons d'édition devenu studios de
cinéma se livrent à une guerre sans
merci
le but aujourd'hui régné sur le
box-office des icônes en combi
alors avec près de quatre films par an
depuis dix ans quel studio est la
stratégie la plus payante
comment les deux franchises parviennent
dallas se démarque et sur quels
personnages leur avenir va-t-il se jouer
en trois rounds chicza fait tout faux
licra va refaire le match et iron man il
est copain avec watan il va déterminer
qui de dc ou de marvel possède les super
héros qui font le plus d'étincelles
[Musique]
à
à ma gauche marvel à ma droite dc comics
deux maisons d'édition fondée dans les
années 30 début du match crochet du
droit en 1933 dit silence un petit gars
2 p à la kryptonite super mal
sept ans après marvel riposte avec
captain america à héros patriotique qui
combat les neiges très rapidement les
aventures de l'un et de l'autre cartonne
trente ans plus tard les deux éditeurs
n'ont pas chômé et se sont constitués de
véritables armes et batman green lantern
flash et wonder woman chez dc les 4
fantastiques hulk thor spiderman iron
man et les x men pour marvel dc a très
tôt incarner des valeurs de justice de
courage d'honneur avec les personnages
de marvel je parlerais plutôt de de
liens ou d'empathie avec avec le lecteur
de l'époque on a des personnes qui
cherche tout le temps à s'inclure à
s'intégrer dans une communauté qui le
rejette
contrairement à dc qui incarne dans
l'hérault en fait incarnent plus l'ordre
et m marvel en descendant le super héros
de son piédestal le rendant vulnérable
en prise avec des situations du
quotidien le rend plus populaires auprès
du public
marvel un dc comics 0 2e round
le passage de la bd au ciné dc comics
racheté par les studios warner en 1969
est la première à avoir l'idée de passer
de la case à l'image et c'est superman
qui ouvre le bal d'abord en séries télé
en 66 puis évidemment au cinéma en 78
avec christopher reeves
bravo mr
[Musique]
résultat plus de 300 millions de dollars
de recettes kryptonite in the new black
l'offensive est lancée
marvel n'a rien vu venir pendant vingt
ans avec pourtant dix films seulement
10,6 seul sur le marché donnait son
approche esthétique du film de
super-héros inauguré avec le batman de
tim burton consacre le genre ici va
confier ses héros donc ses valeurs
incarnées à des à des hauteurs 7 et tim
burton euros dans les années 80 ce sera
juste majeur dans une autre mesure plus
récemment on a eu nos lan qui se sont
vraiment tous ont parait vraiment des
personnages qui ont fait leur version
ces faits le batman de tim burton
c'était le batman de nolan
un choeur a cappella winehouse je vois
plutôt que chez marvel des faiseurs
d'excellents faiseur en a plus quelque
chose de très étals très égal dans la
qualité mais on soit pas définir le
style vraiment pas réalisateur sur les
films marvel
un partout
aux mondes mais au début des années 2000
marvel se réveille le premier film de la
franchise x men va poser des bases de ce
que va devenir la conception marvel du
film de super héros
ce qui fait qu marvel est largement en
avance aujourd'hui sur dc comics c'est
que marvel a su mettre en pratique
l'univers partagé entre super héros qui
allait être la marque de fabrique de
marennes dans les années à venir et en
2009 la firme se transforme en rouleau
compresseur
après avoir été racheté par disney
l'interconnectivité des personnages
c'est que tout est possible et que les
histoires sont renouvelables à l'infini
tout et où des seuils de courir après
cette formule soit disant magique de
l'univers de franchise interconnectés
pour l'instant il que marvel qui est
vraiment réussi à le faire
pour l'heure avec en tout 48 films pour
marvel et 29 pour dc le bilan est sans
appel
l'armure d'iron man éclipse largement le
pet signal au box office avait une
chance rapporte un milliard et demi de
dollars
avengers d'ailleurs dû le crew 1,4
milliard et iron man 3 1,2 milliard
le batman de nolan arrive en cinquième
place avec un petit milliard pour de
docteur house et marvel 2 6 6 1
dernier round l'avenir et l'avenir pour
dc comics et de tenter de jouer dans la
même cour que son rival de toujours en
se mettant au film de man sur la fiche
de justice league
les choses sont énoncés clairement vous
ne souffrez pas le monde seuls cantons
estimé m déclaration qui peut se lire
aussi comme un mantra superman ou batman
ne peuvent pas à eux seuls sous les 10
donc on les met dans le même film et on
rajoute wonder woman et aquaman et de
flash l'enjeu pour warner et dc avec
justice league
c'est vraiment de réussir leur avengers
à eux de réussir leur équipe de
super-héros leur leur dream team de
super héros qui serait l'acte de
naissance vraiment de cet univers
cinématique de dc comics et warner qui
répondrait à l'univers cinématique de
marvel et disney avec avengers voilà si
dc comics est à la traîne
justice league va certainement relancer
les dés et dans une guerre où tous les
coups sont permis
ici vient tout juste piqué à marvel
brian michael bendis un de ses
scénaristes historique
[Musique]